hola qué tal pues básicamente se espera
que esta noche a diferencia de los dos
días anteriores que vimos el primero en
donde el tema principal fue la unidad
ayer el liderazgo y el tema serán la
inmigración y un discurso más de
inclusión hacia las minorías no
solamente los afroamericanos sino
también los inmigrantes que viven en los
eeuu el discurso central será de la
candidata a la vicepresidencia
kamala harris pero también se espera que
el ex presidente barack obama sea muy
firme y más fuerte en el tono de su
discurso haciendo un listado de digamos
lo que consideran los demócratas lo que
han sido un fracaso de las políticas del
presidente de donald trump para hacer
frente a la pandemia también se esperan
vídeos hay que recordar que esta
convención es virtual y los demócratas
grabaron más de mil vídeos para poder
tener estos cuatro días de transmisión
así que veremos más vídeos de ciudadanos
que muestran sus problemáticas y lo que
esperan de bailén si llega a ser
presidente así que será una noche en
donde veremos a líderes y personajes
tradicionales del partido demócrata
bien diana castañeda pues estaremos
pendientes contigo y con más
corresponsables